[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but we love laughs welcome to the ILO's
podcast and the Lords of Jerry J episode
noble won't go to checkout it's 48
it's the glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable or the Lord's Day today
we've got our packs recap Final Fantasy
7 remake impressions ps4 2020 lineup and
is III filing on its deathbed to discuss
so we go get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original Lords in a realm here at
the roundtable Michael's with the cold
most my brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror Lord of reviews
and the half of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir I'm doing
pretty good shot on the startup screen
but the more hit your button OBS is like
look you know the audio don't work at
all anymore I'm sorry make sure they try
to say ok they said you do it like a
protest like you try to get paid stars
you know what one thing that you all
want to point out is King got me hooked
on this gears pop a little bit yeah you
know you know attic I want I want to
shout out to all you frauds Oh get this
you go get this work Butler put it out
shut up for all you frauds are yo when
we saw gas pop when Microsoft put it on
stage and then the game came out nobody
said a word all you frauds that
downloaded it and got it in your phone
or you lose Sony pony heads it's burning
your phone you know you love the game
absolutely non-stop yo when I'm in
destiny on a loading screen
I'm yes but that's cuz you are that's
not because you are calling so you're on
PC you oh oh oh um I got some news for
you brother
oh it just big gears pop at it wow go
back boys yeah I like yeah i originate
it from like you know the platformers
the banjo kazooie stuff like that but
you know when it come to that I was just
like you know I stopped I went towards
more the RPG air but this game really
like show me is like yo you still like
platformers mm-hmm that's what's up
knowing that we there's rumors that's a
log that has I had some coverage on that
you just make sure the podcast read City
slip oh man uh brother $6 suit said
thank you for your coverage at PAX East
yahwah's out there grinding thank you
Lord no lecture please x NT x 2 we put
one out before all work all the super
church from before we do appreciate
everything
and yeah I was gonna read it from before
Verdun scream love and of course we have
returning our most technical gaming Lord
the solo gamer who lives for the
single-player selfish experience and
also the sastra Damas mister a flat
profile Illuminati in lower pay shot of
the iron baked mom made Lord sovereign
how you doing sir I am done I think I'm
running on like ten hours to sleep over
like like three days talk about the
fight last night I would if I had you
know I even forgot it was on and when I
woke up this morning I said the only
thing I can hear when you said that is
maybe combat chunk will be as long right
now oh my god we got a twenty dollar
super chat from Kat any fat stacks much
love to you guys for all the awesome
packs shout out to dizzy stay strong
brother
oh yeah WWF 95 arcade game is currently
underway today yeah I said Jake kid
covet mercy was on the music and stuff
in it is incredible I wish I would have
had macho at that time but macho was
covering Final Fantasy no I didn't have
a person for interviews oh you don't
watch over Z that far on that so a lot
of times if you see our videos with a
without an interview is because
well I didn't say this dough right he
was writing he was interviewing was you
know covering covering game yeah what
macho was doing all the work you guys
did Lord gene Lord macho hi now go old
school and of course YouTube I've got a
funny Bob Dunn story really killed it we
got it we got a blood dollar super trap
from Smitty again I've never knew how
much I miss Auburn into yeah yeah you
would sorry and look I bought suit yes
yeah but we we we got situations in it
set that uh we gonna have we should be
able to have a team on every aisle yes
down bro we go kill what you your shower
three shadows real quick yeah we got
short loud Lord mock moods in the chat
that's way hick that's my boy right
there he's been hold us down with the
articles or packs once we've been
putting up the footage he's a B C's a
machine I got a salute them
you know I'm say it's not oh you already
know your shout out to your OCD star
though cuz much I give you crap you
shout to his drop-off forget it man on a
trip so I'm giving you credit you don't
say school talk was up in the building
to get a couple of interviews in there
oh
shout out to chew game a 90 CLA with the
$10 switcher great coverage from pax
guys think think that was many that we
are super chair set out to do while and
in Streets of Rage for how was the music
in streets rates for though I know okay
here's the real quick give it to you
real quick all right there's the the
beat the beat that we did inside the
boom-boom room
remember the tweeze in the boom-boom
room for a little bit you don't play
outside
wheezing a boo-boo rule is some cereal a
Gary shout to select cereal agree with
it with exclusive media access so hablo
there's a bee in that joint that is off
the chain a usual usual concern Kushiro
I believe its neighbors did I'm telling
y'all right now it is yea the beat they
a little different I would say
everything hits but there was three
beats that I was like so trust me they
got the plane home because you know
there was a siren oh he do there's
another sweaty sweaty right now
JD right now you shout - JD gamers just
want to say thank you for the awesome
pax coverage nobody does it like the
laws Bob Baer who got one bad mother
I got it you got a finalist ripchat from
bad mother okay look I'm trying
this is Kings influence now you guys
need to stop soccer eat the super check
and I read the super yeah please
we got s please the five dollar super
check amazing packs coverage you guys
give the Indies their due
IOP does then touch with IG and don't
let me clean that up we gotta fight off
super chatter from the grounded gamer
welcome back lord thank you for all your
PAX East coverage the professionalism
information and fun shine through with
every interview alright final buzzer le
mames salut soda that's been pretty much
it there with that superior Star Wars
you know so I'm not gonna say anything
I'm at a part where I need to reach my
lightsaber I need a new lightsaber
that's all that I stole shout out to
Megatron and shout out to all about to
talk about bloody knuckles shout out to
Megatron and bloody knuckles for being
true friends playing their way out
together and I said then I had a tear in
my heart
you know it's you know it's me kiss me
play through the whole game don't worry
don't worry don't worry I'll play with
you really happy to solve xscape that
prison you left you there you looked you
in that cell to have the Lord's back two
weeks is too long yes it is but it is
too long but of course we have the
Incredible Hulk ernest a.k.a the XS
gamer ooh the lord of combat sports king
of the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement o
beloved
Lord K guy you do exert fresh off their
UFC oh boy that is probably the greatest
woman fight I've ever seen in my life
you know and I would have been happy
with the drawer to be honest with you I
didn't win of the move you don't want to
see nobody lose that it was amazing
there was a knockout drag-out and get
him done for it was so good I was the
dark alley you Besta run brother because
she breaking men down over him all right
mom
what I was playing this week see this is
this is this is where from now on I'm
stop pulling up my arm my game pass I
don't know what but I'm fraud it like I
do 20 hurts though put the big back
camera back
kappa alright so we got all we've got is
we got all p call out game in the homie
we did that one who else we miss oh no
my bad oh he did it again so salute
lords for what you do as a Korean host
of the last City radio gaming podcast
we're always here to support now whose
fraud or ghost this is she oh okay now
what I think he's talking about I
thought I didn't think it was gonna come
out um it was very strategic for Sony to
put it in June and I thought that was a
great idea to make it pay twice you know
y-you know what I saw the genius and you
know what he said he said he gonna bust
your pockets wide open because one you
gonna make you buy it twice you're not
gonna get no upgrade like you know how
Microsoft do is you brought the game
once not doing that so what you gonna do
is you're gonna get the enhanced version
with the PlayStation 5 but you want to
play it now here for the summertime
while you wait for the PlayStation Fire
come out play it goes the Tsushima knock
yourself out in November when the
PlayStation fire hit the deck it's gonna
be right there with the enhanced you
want the ray-tracing version super did
you see her head no accident wait I got
a question how did the planet on her
head compared to the same rock mom
planet how did it compare No
I assume Rahman still win yeah he still
got the worst yeah Rahman he's still
ain't right yo ciudad yo shot the gay
before they welcome back lords last week
was born y'all making us feel listen um
for everybody that join the realm okay
all you guys that join the room but we
told you we was gonna give y'all man
coverage there's a lot of video that the
world doesn't see but you guys get to
see and if you join the room right now
you hit that joint button you will be
privy to a ton of extra video we said
we're gonna give it to you and we gave
it to you but those videos will forever
be locked behind that big wall
so hashtag swipe the card or the plea at
five get out game pass this week um
field Dominus Maximus Spencer is on his
ones and twos his step is so crazy it's
nuts so I said I was never buying
another 2k game of again
yes lo and behold the boy returned on
his game pass and guess what was dead
mmm-hmm that's 20 plus 20 euro Oh cat
daddy welcome back please yo cat daddy
we got an exclusive walkthrough please
check that out for members ooh another
thing hit a senate dm's because
something was talking about before
mm-hmm okay so i going through the app
to tell you what I was playing um
shoutout to Laura Cognito will put me on
for two point Hospital
you always on the train before we start
with walibi I will just take my El now
so give me the bending me now Attucks
let's get it over with hold on because I
know to the shields up Carlisle gaming
those packs use visible fire Lords I got
to go to go to bend Ania let me get this
over with so in my defiance with King we
only doing our train ride into tax so
I've got my sweets already put up the
bend the knees I'm gonna get that box
open and ready this receipt the knees
you know so I downloaded Kingdom Hearts
3 he wouldn't play these games if they
were gay Pegg definitely I'm already
maxed out one character so what you do
they say well the Kings got a crazy PC
that's right here on the side right
TI's running our low opinion
alright to put that to work so my did so
guess what I found on on the PC side
this game called death what is it is uh
it's not recently attitude this piece is
a gamepad show i'ma tell you right now
that game is so magnificent if you got
PC game on game pass yes
Oh gambit okay yo the animations on that
it's like a Dark Souls but to D mmm it's
so hot I was like what am i doing I
gotta be playing on my PC now um rain
bound umm don't wanna Phil kept pushing
can fill cap what you saw it on every
sizzle reel you seen rain boundary and
man that game is so good me and my son
was playing so let's talk cog now train
and I'm in my bag and you know and Lord
snow those sitting in front of me
everybody they switch but I'll have ice
which would I have my chest I was I was
about to start auto with this two-point
hospital just put us on game pass
fulfill so you talking about Phil got
that right there what are you talking
about - what I just came out that brain
you know you know what a Sony dudes be
like so
that's PC only consult no I was like the
L was handed I thought there was no way
that gay was gonna be a pass he's still
got his knee cuz we play yours now to a
real real quick cake is a I think about
the look did you see the main event at
all those a day asking yeah I'll do a
recap quick or Magi will be welcome to
the welcome to the realm put the crest
up ask my guy right there will be I will
meet you guys eventually I guess I
appeared in a couple of phantom photos
yeah we met your counterpart we met you
Chris yeah easy
so what are we we to four one three
University made it with six one three
but um shout out to wicked good gaming I
want y'all to go to the podcast I
definitely want you to like follow and
subscribe that week that we was off we
did a show with them yeah that show is
so incredibly nuts you definitely have
to go check it out yeah I was a
hilarious show shopping with you good
games in the building okuu down Bob
Chris the crew so much fun yo that a
safari room
[Music]
but Esther has to Bettany a sir
every year you go to I'm tell you right
now we've been a lot of conventions you
know say it was a movie for facts you
know the GP they look at Gigi's aha
yeah we saw you gue velvet is but up
yeah bill every time we've been to a
bunch of parties a bunch of afterparty a
bunch of stuff with all these
conventions and King it's not even close
to be real that is something at the
bottom oh geez just go to click the
where says I lost podcast and oh jeez
who did their for you like this you know
I think I worked very hard on these
let's get those up exactly I'm saying
but yes saluted up dudes man but yeah
real quick to fight very boring um is he
very defensive um but then what you
wasn't doing anything he just jumping up
in place and I mean he like he he wasn't
active he try to be aggressive the only
thing I will give on your man is that
you could say dizzy was being a Lou too
defensive but he was power he was was
too respectful in a pie of my opinion I
felt he should have went after him but
it's like Romero's dangerous and there
was a couple times Romero stung him
early and it was kinda like oh yeah yeah
yeah Jose like so he was me dude like
he's but he was just doing like wild
over here right trying to time him you
know I'm saying and then busy was just
destroying his leg like to let his leg
at the end of the fight the welts in his
leg but not be any ground attempts from
Romero he tried wanted to but he really
is not a wrestling like that everybody
was saying Joe Rogan was saying he's
like yo he should
Eliza's wrestler he did take him down
once how is he cop right back you know
at the end of the day the problem with
this joint is that you can't sell a Joe
Jones fight after this because they're
gonna be like nah you're supposed to go
blitz him out of there and you know it
is what it is but that's what I got it
was nothing you ain't miss enough it has
a snorefest it was and it was brewing at
the end Romero was bad English fight it
was bad after part was funny and it was
booing him and then dizzy was like yo I
did what I had to do you know one of
them tight moves you know I'm saying so
I think they go set up the what's the of
a boy Kosta Kosta probably be next so
that that's pretty much it but King
that's are we done with our game pass -
you know my shot out the Sinister before
I played it on the PC mm-hmm because
they was doing the floors in the back
there's putting a new I'm the new statue
room was going on you know the air and
stuff in here so I'm gonna put those
cabinets over there but let me let me
give a shout out to I think was Mike
Ibarra oh um that overlay that virtual
console thing for Xbox we gotta give it
right we gotta talk is Mikey bar was
definitely part of it yes but we gotta
give also credit game ball to our man
Lord Dan McCulloch head of Xbox Live who
we had on IOP before and yet ad that's a
baked potato you mess around with it
when I put it on mm-hmm my xbox popped
up on my PC yeah and I was in the chats
talking to green Mason and Harlan wizard
and I'm there playing that and I'm over
here playing this PC game yeah we're
talking and I can go and see what
everybody else is doing then I pull up
the game pass and you know what it is is
it's like I understand your fear and
Sony guys
because it's like going to IOP and going
to loads of gaming down then you see oh
my god this is a real website this is
crazy it's the same feeling when you put
it on I was like oh my god if if this
the world really gets out feel bad
pities buddy tell me what I fear King oh
other Zico you dick our DNA to your they
going to continue but we got pictures
together I was like yo the multi prong
approach that then use that Microsoft is
incredible yeah it has a little bugs in
it am I gonna lie I can't afford say oh
it was clean and I couldn't do I could
do everything no sometimes you have to
wait for certain things like your
refresh and stuff but i'ma tell you the
audio was clear because Mason told me he
said to hell microphone you use them and
I had to take a picture of Mike that I
was using you used it on xbox I said no
I'm downstairs on my PC what the
pictures I got a video with you four
members only
that's our first meeting oh yeah it was
you in short capri we get a bit is
behind-the-scenes I see a separate ghost
in his bag me and and that's kind of
crazy because it brought me full circle
when we supposed in these videos No
and that yo yes except there's no live a
video let's get a lot of people anyway
can I get my balls off we have the
shinobi nor kognito spreading that
realness in the ramen ILP not telling
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear yo finally settling down from
pax man a lot of work a lot of work man
salute to all y'all
they definitely appreciated everything
that was that was love you boy and get a
chance to do much game because he's
giving y'all content you know they shot
the king which is uploading and
uploading shout out to the writers oh
let me tell you how shout out the you
attic which a thumbnail game you know
using a using a bad kid gone okay I know
he was tired of King video salute today
a weighty man cuz we gave you a lot of
work Jerry you don't say raid virus to
kill work say so the war is not over now
when I go to e3 it's your turn you gonna
be doing some J so yes look at that but
um yeah man like I said I already got a
chance to really stick in the Final
Fantasy 7 demo we'll talk about that on
that topic or annex topic and then
finally last night snuck in a little bit
of trials practice do an elimination
getting ready for my Lubas get my
Pharaoh Djoser
so I got a mess around with all the
metas trying to see you try to have a
sweatiest lineup what's gonna be the
sweatiest you'll see guns I could bring
in there cuz is it's gonna be real
Charlie Rose comes back next Friday I'm
ready it was uncomfortable with the the
amount of super chance to hit that chat
I might tell my personal experience I
have my boss called me out for being on
a podcast yo that was sad
oh yeah I don't know about the anti
chief slow I don't know but we go we go
see what it's gonna be brought up yeah I
might try to do that on Xbox let's see
but anyway enough for that yo it's that
time of the buffs off you know how we do
we got a thank you to all our supporters
I'm gonna start off with our but our
patreon supporters of course are forever
are forever patron Cory night Nick
whiskey baby all repeal we coming up on
the 24 for your up services we lost our
brother there'll be almost a full year
so yes Luke whiskey we miss you brother
always in our hearts you already know
[Laughter]
Latinos don't sting that's a big yes
Latino Jay oh thanks to the Lords of
gaming for the PAX East coverage loving
knows in these in these matter yo shout
out the king on that to give that up the
King King Yoda he's a PR dream Indies
they love the cake good see you exoti
Lord HP 33 thank you sir
followed by Lord make seven masters or
novocaine and okay let me know if you've
received that yet because yes brother
get your rewards off please
no no but he did contact me it's just
you know how oh yeah
LC 1 1 2 1 new to the realm of patreon
thank you so much mm-hmm fastback 67 68
whoa gee the Lord of all things Nintendo
switch switch pockets and of course in
the community to a gaming Fords of Lords
of game net Lord undead assisted
editor-in-chief Steven Terry see you
[Laughter]
next up we have Lord linchpin thank you
Germany oh wow
- George Jamison Jamie Provera me so I
super jet is this enough for the story
addict
also what shadow of Colossus with shadow
colossal PS now what are your thoughts
on it one of the greatest for me solve
you you rock when to shed the shadow of
Colossus I mean it's a it's kind of a
one for one movie make except that it's
much prettier yeah it's beautiful
controls a little bit like it made it a
little more accessible it's still kind
of weird control wise hmm but yes that's
a good look I purchased it already so
that's one of my you know nothing
nothing a lot of my PlayStation games I
like to own um because if they did the
storage of a narrative they're really
pretty
and sometimes those games for me become
like collectors I say that PlayStation
now extinction later the podcast I will
say I will tell the boss story yes that
he was to here that's he put the super
chatty before continue did you'd open
your mouth please will be hood with the
$100 suture Wow I hit that like and
subscribe thank you but let me tell you
man will be is one of the most positive
people in the community we're doing
something extremely special this
Thursday and you know mostly you guys
already know so I can spoil it but um
yeah hopefully we got some really big
guests we're gonna do something very
special in um realm for our brother Lord
dizzy you know I'm saying and um it's
gonna go out for cancer research we're
gonna support you know what's going on
my brother dizzy has an amazing article
right now
Gaming with cancer he's touched a lot of
people he touched me I told him when
even I was reading it man you got you
got tears in my eyes on that final
subheading and final four paragraphs so
please you know I'm saying support us it
will be on boom show double-barrel
gaming officer friendly we will do it I
think the time is 8 p.m. will me we're
gonna have a huge surprise guest really
knows we're gonna talk about I believe
also ran down Thor's gonna do the
community is gonna come together we're
gonna talk about gamers suffering in
silence gamers we can't gamers with
cancer you know hide our admins also
doing some stuff when up we really gonna
bring awareness to this and we're really
gonna show out so please if you support
I love podcast you support will me like
he's doing please also support boom
double-barrel gaming history I believe
it's 8:00 p.m. Eastern yeah Thank You
Willie for correcting me it's going to
be a movie and we're gonna do something
big for the community so salute to my
brother
we'll meet up for the reminder thank you
sir continues off alright so next up we
have Lord and the odds Loma [ __ ] oh
that's that's my guys like I believe
he's a lawyer as well slow and we have
Lord seafood poetic initiative yes
that's that guy right there Fred of the
ramp you're a nerve mmm good team then
our brother that is definitely not from
across the pond Lord Sammy Prescott and
of course nor chocolate died himself
Lord shut the propose or breath he's got
this slandering me lying on my knees in
that we want to put that fraud a look
therefore be of sand at the castles they
hold it stuff back and I was like what
do you doubt this coach at the slow
motion of the game but they had me so
bad and then what been only what's funny
you're talking on his PC bastard
yeah I'm gonna tell them I have to
answer to his crimes against humanity we
have the Lord of the Lord and the other
dude a lemon apologies family from the
cradle to the grave some sauce one it's
like some beef go door continues oh yo
real rock whatever
[Laughter]
we cheat how holy he always all about
them fights he always would have here
with us we gotta save on you see Lord of
the double dip thank you so much sir
doors C D F s look too cold
look at daddy ah and of course we have
North Jameson Sheamus is in yellow thank
you so much appreciated of course last
but never least Lord n singer thank you
so much Alisa
saying go Yuri know what my XCOM bredrin
right I went to our YouTube supporters
thank you so much especially apologies
to the guys that are not well we shouted
you out but the gay the guys that signed
up today I will definitely get you in
April so we got or filly eagle thank you
the blue one that is a 2000 at the
railway it's a relic like the blue my
lord sleepy goblin to D into D best name
have a best platformer name contain ever
ever we have learned night music thank
you for the support gamer by choice
which content so much you decided to
support us on two fronts Lord speech to
company which pocket oh I'm not
condoning none of this we should change
the logo with just three switches
he's like I'm canceling bushes
[Laughter]
that's fine I know you could do it shout
out like music you can bust some kind of
moves you are amazing with the stick a
while salut salut will be heard when we
all get a little older when you give
shout out for medical support you're
[Music]
next up shout out to the Lord being
blackmailed aka Lord pixel gaming Forte
thank you sir always support even
support one last word much though this
collection is insane wait till you see
the next stuff I mean you know you see
some solve get your [ __ ] rape I
wouldn't know anything about that and
see that I wouldn't come gaming Forte
thank you sir no of course thank you for
the support my brother yes sir restored
Hades woo in the building
yo washroom sir that that's at the
sticker is of Jim Ryun dancing wrestling
name in the building Lord Titus right
the original Lords in the realm Lord 0i
l piece of loot og and we have Lord
tempest son thank you so much thank you
sir
and we have nor death singer with the
double dip thing oh brother
in the realm baby yes and we have Lord
old school himself schools technical
sector the hardware guru sir then we
have another Lord of combat talk Lord
eternal side I oh yeah it's the box of
jewelry dissolute and we have Lord
Hollow
thank you for holiday didn't it all
salute but not least Lord Smitty Smith
thank you for that's the homie I much
like every time we put some out he
supports me salute him in Nova silly I
believe you those two never a sum of RP
go up on it or the channel they the
first in there miss Luke no doubt so
let's go to give a raise real quick you
go none of stuff you're gonna start to
get this stuff mmm dollar gift card
giveaway goes to Lord Sifu poetic
missionary first I believe all but we're
winning that's what sub salute you're
able God you got you then we have $10
gift card giveaway difficult with a lot
of these norm how to do it we got okay
so we're Lord Lynch got you thank you so
much my brother okay let's do this
spring giveaway what a trip what a trip
I know I don't know but this is par for
the course for us oh you know our newest
patron Lord
Luke Laurell see it's not rigged today
our AG's working in separate one one of
the best audio Xbox podcast somebody
with Xbox expansion events go check them
out y'all the chat real quick ok next
week we're gonna have a community event
when the IOP I'm going to be asking the
members and the patrons what type of
format you guys want because I see a lot
of people on Twitter want us to play a
game and watch and then some people want
to play a game with us and but I want
people put in the chat what one you
would prefer because you know obviously
this is a community event so the
community has every right to put the
input on it so never we put in that
child how about you use the poll feature
from the community subscribers and as
there are subscribers what they feel how
about I get concrete evidence as the
co-host what you did I get a chance to
Bob whatever the week come over I got
started cocky you gave me the reins I
can mute you power down
it's not that there's not both it's just
I want because for this first one I want
to hit the one that everyone wants and
then we'll switch back and forth between
them dizzy correct how about play on the
website yes hide we have that
functionality it's something we could do
but you know we good we good thank you
guys alright much appreciated no doubt
definitely always a pleasure to have
that done in the round giving back to
the community um so no Oh last week
because obviously we were at PAX so that
is going on but we'll have a new one up
later in the show so we gonna get right
into these topics out of the intro is
done so lord King this is being you
first um obviously we're at PAX it was a
lot going on
you're I'm saying and what a surprise we
don't want people to think that people
just be rolling up in your vitals happy
in the realm so let's get a lot we got
Lords of gaming's old G let's make sure
his bike is good J by check Mike are you
there sir yeah I'm good of course we
have another of luck that's funny so I'm
seeing some weird scream I don't know
it's cool so like a telescope it's it's
so one yeah is that Lord MOT show of
Lords gaming that net is Mike Snider
from stitch if I thought that the switch
was a real console I would support it
but I can
say that it is when it doesn't do 1080p
stop GOG
you better of playing the X the X cloud
on your phone you want a real mobile
experience macho macho yessir
yes term here yes I'm a rising log
that's independent lot to talk about
this topic obviously the laws with
coverage this was what about 80 percent
I couldn't do that or the Train sir I
couldn't he didn't want to play the
Train tax but he no I was sitting right
there ready to post those pictures and
let y'all know that he's a fraud I am
sorry but X classic rabbits were not met
by an tracks Wi-Fi switch on it either
so don't you worry about it let's go we
got to get into it man um obviously PAC
sees water floors you got 80% of the on
the floor team here so let's start
actually before we start with lawmakers
we got long that in you know say I want
to start first with addict and solve you
know obviously you guys were there but I
want to get your impression of what you
saw from us from PACs or just anything
that stood out like what was your feel
soft you can go first
mmm-hmm I mean I haven't I I saw the
initial videos right I'm like okay they
did they doing that you know they have
plenty of coverage I didn't I didn't
even see like the the downpour of stuff
that came afterwards like all the stuff
that came afterwards if you guys
continuously uploading like I haven't
got a chance to see like half of that
stuff so again shout out to you guys the
amount of content you guys would have
cut out was absolutely ridiculous the
way you guys had it organized everything
was fantastic I honestly I was so tight
at myself and not being absolutely it
was no way around it I couldn't
women and I was I was jealous not to be
there but you guys you guys absolutely
killed it um for me fix anything else
for you and out stuff obviously the
stuff on the floor that the smaller
stuff that that that's what we go there
for to give that stuff a spotlight was
fantastic but this year being that every
do you guys are all media honestly I was
I was floored cuz I mean car keep stuff
close to the chest right know about this
I saw coming
no that was crazy to me and also like I
had to go attic IDM Lord Moscow cuz I
know I know he was in the position I was
in last year right and I know the king
went up to him at his mic it didn't
happen like that we was at the shout out
to Airbnb that we was at it was watch it
was clean it was nice um it was
definitely function it was very workable
than the internet was incredible yeah
but we went over some prep early yeah oh
so um being that you know it's my first
time meeting Lord macho and we trying to
walk them through it
see you I know that you are natural
linguist so you definitely you're fluent
on your feet and stuff like that and me
you've been vibing for forever so we
basically got video um
unspoken words that you know we just
look at each other eyes and we know
where we're gonna go with it I had to
build that rapport with him so we
started off with basic questions and
stuff like that walk them through it
that day in an in the evening cuz I'm
gonna get there early you know game
playing with them so um he was it was
good in that setting but then when we
got to the floor just like you said I'm
like I are you ready let's go anyway
what it do
obviously you know Attica do you want to
go 60 you think I'm interrupting your
your shine I want to transition from
what Soph had said you know into
obviously you know saying the commie and
Jenna which was which is pretty big for
us
and obviously GOG Nandlal macho you know
this year you've been gene you and we
met at PAX previous it's not your first
packs but little macho this was your
first pack so let's get macho first and
gene you know your experience how does
he feel about packs you know in general
well well yeah with it
let's just say my man uh when I got back
to my regular job I was depressed man I
lived a dream for the weekend those
developers it was it was unreal like we
came in from cambia we both look at you
like did it happen that happen mmm das
me for every interview because it was
talking to passionate people about what
they love and what they're making for
the past few years or that year just one
person or ten people it was absolutely
incredible
yeah absolutely a salute to you on the
editing skills you learned about some
new talents look I can saved us in a
bind I know she'll salute to you your
grind this man was up with me one two in
the morning we editing and then of
course getting the text getting the
subtitle game correct the article game
correct was my man no gene or the for
the floor looking like a boss might I
might say it's very very studious
brother yet is is sooo jaggedy now I
have a funny quick Lord Lord gene story
John we had a ghost runner interview
right so I'm ready to go goes for us at
you know they put you in the boom-boom
room I call it the boom-boom room when
it's the press room that they keep you
away from the common folk it's the
boom-boom room so all right we go in
there why is luigi already in there with
his hair no the cows schiller like he
had a few couple of jigs like he was
already fraternizing with the developers
before we got do you be comfortable out
here we're so low G let's get it to you
but how is your experience would you
stand out from what from pax well I know
these events a lot so it was really cool
for me to just not have to wait in line
I grew from
were there with me and to get into doom
they waited in line for two and a half
hours Wow and you just whoop ass with ya
Gosselin pretty much in so to get the
plane were we get to experience more and
we get to talk to people and and being
able to make those appointments in
advance I talked to a ton of publishers
and and my strengths not so much like
being in front of a camera and
interviewing people though Kamiya Inaba
thing was pretty cool I was really I'm
not gonna let it go you want to talk
about some great editing that we were
doing and yo I gotta talk about it hello
there
would call me of course I got a jean
story
I know because y'all about to get lit
let's get my lord
Jean Starr was at the ASA party so we
all get today support and Lord Jean
sends a picture to car we yo we was
clowning we was clowning the hell out of
you we was going to go to the Polish
party yeah gonna happen so he says the
picture this is the Polish party and I
swear I saw tumbleweed in the middle so
I'm like this to the girl behind me
bringing the trees around with the fool
literately
I don't kill I swear I don't know how
you did it I don't know how fast yo him
literally after I sort of pictured I got
my drink she just poured my drink gene
pops up and he's like what's up guys
and he was bringing the food around
on that evening gene done got the suit
jacket off he got the IOP shirt popping
because leave prompting shoutout to
wicked the game is shout out to my
counterpart counterpart Rob four one
three yes sir
he explains something to me we took care
that she doing that so gene understood
that that shirt needs to be seen so his
suit jacket was off and he was in his
back he lived his greatest life I'm
still saluted oh because now think they
was ready for the the majesty the
gloriousness oh the ace of party yo say
cuz look we worked hard yeah we all work
hard and you gotta have balance right
you gotta have that balance when we do
it all this coverage you do a lot of
stuff and we gotta hit up a spot and um
shouting I guess they wait to the ponies
like shows hit off the Polish developer
party you know I'll let you know what's
going on
so we already was going on with a CJ so
when he hit us with the pig I say yo get
over here now
and then we chili a dish the low bar to
the bottles get a little silly shot the
partner maybe what though
though that was definitely a joy but
real quick back back to the games you
know we have fun but just real quick I
wanted to get from y'all like Eddie
moombas gene you know for you personally
you know I'm saying that stood out you
know I'm saying game why is anything
fall guys animal crossing disk room yes
Sniper Elite VR mmm maneater yes Streets
of Rage oh yeah oh yeah that's a fact
no guys was amazing we got an article up
on the site about it
that game is either going to come out
and disappear that week or it's gonna be
the next rocket league I'm not sure yet
but that game was
it was a ton of fun salut to you they
should have got the video of me even
playing Windjammers yeah should be yeah
yeah oh we didn't there was no money to
catch the capture okay being sort of
fanboying out over this game right so I
roam in this field for the game and
interview that tomorrow I was inside the
boom-boom room me and gene slid over to
the side he put my head pause yo
Windjammers - if your Windjammers fan it
everything it's definitely fun so you
already know that's what's obviously
yeah any standouts oh heck for you man
any like key moments just moments also -
you can mention yeah I was just going
around the floor and see how excited
people were for all these games are
coming out it was it was awesome to see
everything that was either in production
and just about to come out that year and
to see the crowd around some of these
games were awesome Tamara when it was me
hiding King let's go see I think it's
call it just shapes and beats and
definitely streets rates for we did that
first interview yeah that was as hype as
could get for the first thing that we
did it that was literally the first
thing day what was cool about it's
probably one of our most viewed videos
right now and I'll pee and what was kind
of cool about it was just like that the
playful nature all of us together all
playing something and having a ball
you know I'm saying it was really cool
to to capture you actually captured for
the job interview and I'm hyping it up I
rewatched it was laughing my son like we
just had so much fun with that you know
since I was deaf I great I was
definitely a highlight Lord addict man
got ask you I know like I said for me
outside looking in any other stuff that
you put up for us and helped us out we'd
really stood out to you anything that
caught your eye and there's no bushes
so Eddie this Ematic I started digging
deep in these games your final fantasy
was amazing to me is really amazing to
you sir what did you saw is what you
asked me sorry my brother was being so
good this look good what a foot of
coverage that you've been helping us out
with you know saying on the road
Oh what kind of stood out to you that
you had your eye on that you like yo I
like this joint that they did or just
any game in particular anything stand
out like shadow at a role play this it's
gonna come out sometime I looked on they
said like 2021 Bros a double angle and
let's talk about it that's what's up yes
so that now one particular yeah really
nice I really liked what I saw by
wasteland yes shot the PD on that me
just because Square Enix deemed your
game not better than mine does not mean
that you can make those kind of comments
she said we got continuous hateful Final
Fantasy 6 talk about anything that it
doesn't compare to talk about
I'm sorry screams to be making six they
not they make two clutch man on one
which I arranged for can't wait brother
date and date season up later this is a
xbox game passing out no doubt he shot
the one bad mother-- wastefully 83
definitely everybody sleep it on X in
exile
two slow effects it looks phenomenal
let's get to the king man King you did a
lot of coverage we were on the second
team we split up into different units of
teams moving on the floor collectively
you gotta say I got a chance to see some
of the stuff like what are some of the
highlights the standouts for you adpacks
well I want to say first um I didn't get
a chance to see a lot of guys like um I
definitely wanted to see you know
warhorse studios to get over there and
check out the new games over there um so
I trust me I tried to get to that side
and just the standouts
you wanna you wanna say Streets of Rage
as your ultimate stand out because the
level of fun yeah it captured from I see
I remember the first time sheets of Rage
came out because it was like the combat
final fight that was on this one really
got in a bag to get this game to us to
satisfy their core base that's when the
competitive nature force companies to
either me to either get out or lay down
and for this game to come back now right
it's it's it's so amazing cuz there's no
Sega mm-hmm right so you're like dag
whatever will we ever get another one so
we saw it last year and we were happy
when we saw it last year because we it
was hope this year it's like they just
took hope and ten folded it was
incredible from the music to the
gameplay so we went to go to the
boom-boom room
right give me a story behind that so we
went to we had to interview now and your
time was right but there was another
interviewer that was inside the
boom-boom room I saw the develop his
face and the developer was like geez
yeah he was stopping either I throw this
dude out or tell him through the way I'm
in a rock and a hard place so you know
maybe perfect call as a manager I
already scoped out what was happening in
the front there was nobody there yet I
was four seats in the front
finish your interview he's gonna go
capture footage and gameplay over here
and that was so amazing crazy game I'm
go over here touch your stuff it was a
win-win good call King that was all you
because at the end of the day like you
said his face he was he was stuck like
he was witted nothing me ain't gonna
throw the guy out but he knew he had the
commitment to us and then you made the
call and then that end up being
literally out of all our foot is
funneling as far as YouTube footage
that's the biggest viewed as far as you
know to the technical interview with him
his level of energy that he gave you
when you came back he's like comedy in
they know you know cuz everybody thinks
because you got that media badge that
you can just be Bogart and your way into
stuff like we are they're in a report
this is a barter system you have
something our cover and I have something
that you want out I mean so so we are
working together so when when my Cho my
one of my best healer for the show is
talk to me
she'll got his first interview yeah he's
like you want to start over now brother
keep it going facts because sometimes
you don't get it do over but the best
articles and interviews you're gonna get
is sometimes in those mistakes and it
was a long interview took that same
energy because if you get to his last
interview his last review is with the
same guy with Vlad mmm it's the next day
and this is last interview and you can
tell macho is in his bag and and shout
out to Boston Convention Center for
making me feel safe spotless yeah we
gotta gotta talk is one individuals not
nuts that's not fresh if you go into
these convention places and you go into
places where is a lot
people hotdog water guy wash I wanted
all that pre rail and pour it all over
his body but macho and Vlad had
interview and took off his mask and Vlad
was in the bag it has another indie dev
name shout-out to that company because
it was it was great to see we started
building reporting because they sorted
shirts and it was like oh I remember you
from this time yes and it felt so good
it felt like you know like you like home
be honest with you we understood how to
floor work now because you know year ago
we didn't understand how the numbers
work yeah so going down its Giga bash
I like Giga bash if I'm gonna take any
game away from packs then I cannot wait
for and I and I honestly will believe
it's gonna be a sleeper hit it's gonna
probably be kunai mmm
yeah Kuna is the game that I obsessed
over that I I can't wait to get my hands
on if you check out the footage go see
it it's a roguelike game and your little
robot and he's a ninja and he has these
cool knives and it's his Metro vania
type yes it's so simplistic but so
beautiful in his artistry that I was
blown away from the Streets of Rage guys
I really I thought that was probably one
of the best games that I've seen there
it was no triple a banger but it's a
double a boom like yeah that's what I
took away from that yeah man Indies are
jumping again these wanna rise that's
that's the first thing I saw offer it
you know we got there you know um shout
to the devs like I said cuz everybody
did know I was gonna play out with the
virus we will not talk about we should
not name on YouTube TV burners about a
child know what it is is like you know
we didn't know how I was gonna play out
but the numbers were switch tremendous
people came out in droves it was crazy
shout out to the Patti devs though that
they would do they hit you with this
JoJo's rage
shout out to the escalators they had to
provide the sanitizers as you go up at
the bottom and at the top of no with the
US any wipes down the escalator rails
touch that it was cleaning bro literally
I just go down the stairs clean
convention I have ever been about they
were on your salute support secure
better said they were on their job you
was not gonna get anything up in there
you know say Lee at least ornate I'm on
a watch for III again for me to look
over to Boston Convention Center to see
exactly how they manage packs in such a
manner yes you can do that anywhere if
they follow that same formula they file
in a protocol shadow bambe said he said
they had them stationed at all those
people at the door it's like put your
head against the wall but yeah I gotta
go catch a couple of shoutouts man my
spirits on get so first off how are you
saying a kick on makes me like Harlem on
the rise polish studios on the rise
y'all were no problem with them yo
Poland is in the building you know a lot
of these games man I want to give a
shout out bro arm and Shaw studios with
game deck of the one that um shadow with
a road with another angry I know attic
mentioned on ghost run up that joint was
firearm looking games yo shout out to
Shane man it was a gene you you did that
well with us right yes it's great for
player co-op we
to saw what the analog sword control you
can carry you don't saying like I really
like that one Jean I don't know how you
felt I know you got a chance to play
while I was interviewing but you felt
good about it it was like in our kt
battletoads with like a heavy sword
combat yeah and the cool thing is we got
the dev so hyped it was like because we
would like it they said like they came
from beat him up the old school the
street stranger you know i'm saying it
the TA and we mentioned teenage minister
he said yo we'd love to do that game so
i was like yo
whoever's got the rights they ready they
ready this it was lit match it was
definitely you know I'm saying on my
list gaijin are you talking and had a
twin stick combat so you guys the right
analog stick to swing the sword around
yeah that's really cool really really
good man so again I want to shout all
opposed developers that I got a chance
to speak to shadow ruler game was like
XCOM meets feudal Japan with Max and
magic and some mysterious boy that got
powers on the map that was crazy game
deck was like some cyberpunk isometric
joint you know I'm saying agile was fire
you know is my sleep at all ever they
are averse to ever space to home and out
your kid remember then when we had 3d
all right I remember when I first had
three do one of the biggest features
there obviously graphical fidelity of
the 3d [ __ ] and now it was this game
called total eclipse yeah remember how
it changed the game for fidelity for
spaceship fighters you know dad ever
space tool and then on top of that he's
like you know this is open world with
Diablo blue all this stuff like ever
spec that blew me away so just one dude
right um as far as the creation I don't
know if it's one guy that just created
it I know that but the first one this is
a sequel I don't I don't know how many
guys are on the team off top I'm gonna
say they had a team I don't think
there's one person that developed that
one but um yo shout to the community guy
he was he was amazing we had a great
interview that was fantastic
um kind of makes him shot I gotta bring
some petty shouts out solve um
shout out to the switch being very
scalable with the Unity engine because a
lot of the interviews King when I
looking at the graphical fidelity and
they would
yes this is coming to the switch and
I'll be like stop life there's no way
you wrap this around some switch angle
I'm not lying I'm gonna tell you right
now at least in these packs places these
conferences these indie devs 90% of
these games is on a switch if not 98% of
these games to the Unity engine man the
scalability a lot of these games we had
on this amazing scuba dive in looking a
shout there if I'm school tech is in a
joint you know I'm saying hair example
about petty switch getting oh she'll do
one away dragon TV fire switch at PAX
East hey guys ready to give the Rambo
fire hose in the cell wash thanks a
great coverage Zulu LBO salute 108 yards
said you know that's what's up yeah I'm
definitely put my petty bag with the
switch but only because to be honest
like I was truly surprised that these
games can be converted there's this one
game it was called beyond blue it was
like some educational scuba diving
graphics it looked next-gen you could've
tell me that was a PS 5 game and I've
been like y'all I believe you and these
guys are telling me that was scalable
down to switch so that to me was amazing
also I got a shout sketch Tech Talk
estado I met one of my heroes y'all I've
met Eric chahi
shout out to Eric chahi he's the creator
of another world one man made that game
that game is in my top five list I'm
almost to the prime I had to hit a
graphic god we got to redo didn't you I
have to put another world I forgot about
it
that's my gate unity is really
impressive but as far as Eric chahi the
vo shelter GU held down to VR with that
for me you know I'm saying while he's
doing anything to be honest I was just
so happy that they had another person to
talk to with with you so I can have Eric
chahi two buses I know so I was fan boy
like you you got a list it as few people
that you Suzuki Eric
he is a few people I will fanboy that
was definitely on my family it was honor
to meet him so that's his studio he's
doing a lot of Yost I can go front King
I'm frightened I might be interested in
Viana you start the fraud I see a vision
for job in the bag no matter retirement
yeah I gotta put my pocket watching up
in this because Sony definitely gonna
have cog purchase yo I might be
everybody out the bad bit he was there
he saw it was there we were both there
for that head of you you know sale shout
out grab a gun oh I got me on another
world you know if you could get the
point way goes back sure dad oh we don't
talk about them but anyway so that was
that and then the last thing like I say
arm shot to the TV like I said you guys
absolutely killed it we will on our feet
all day
you don't say moving and grooving
appointments and okay good for anybody
that think I was on a vacation cuz
somebody take me oh you had a great
vacation I was like shut the hell up man
every day the level of on my feet miss
like oh okay so when I'm not on my feet
I'm sitting down
I caught a crick in my neck hunched over
uploading video downloading uploading
dumping data checking through stuff
putting stuff up testing an attic the
stuff is up in that excite you
um fax the level I've I don't think I've
worked this hard in actual job and I
can't see you know I can't say some
stupid like actual job because this is
actual Johnson actual job okay so if I'm
sitting here three hours doing a podcast
this is a job um doing video putting
video up and walking and on my feet I
looked at the team not one person
complain no one comes out nobody [ __ ]
door mom
was Sunday sorry Oh Paula knows how we
go to events and stuff like that like
it's not just like you go somewhere for
a couple hours you leave like it's an
all-day thing like all day you are tired
and you can barely walk by noon but you
got to keep going for the rest of the
day
Jenna needle with the 5-hour energy
hookup I was taking little bursts oh no
we gotta give a shout-out though we
really all of us gene um all of us are
heck we got a shout-out star though for
locking down that media room we found
out about that meat that was literally
home base that we could kind of recharge
our batteries we've kind of get things
done
and you gotta tell to Bob don't stop
because now what was it with the young
lady Fotolia productions okay
total game yeah it's about rising hell
rising and coffee talk and so we're
there and we're doing on all the
interviews and we getting down to doing
rising hell so it's Caucasian fellow
walks up to me and he goes hi guys I'm
sorry I'm late I had car trouble and he
has Nona Lords a game you got net shirt
and a suit I said in my head we covered
all the games here I think we you know
we got anything anything else I said
well we got another interview over there
and we got applicator stuff he's
you mind if I tag along this developers
really about ILP and it didn't hit me
until we got to the media room it was
Bob absolutely hilarious 30 that was yo
it was classic man I real quick I what I
got again another shout out so Bochy OG
because for me personally you know the
Platinum Games was such a smashing and
we didn't know to be honest off like we
didn't know how it was gonna play out
they didn't give us too much coming in
it was kind of like meet the connect off
site and you know like Lin was like it
was it was it was like yo you gonna go
off site to a dislocation we shall not
disclose and you're gonna meet the
connect and then when you meet the
connect me connect is gonna take you to
Cali Erbil so we had to beat the boss to
disrupt we talkin a wicked good games
right here it's a good for you
no remorse when he said yeah right by
myself to some place that he found out
he said you do VR you go that way so
okay and then I was sequestered by
myself and he took me some weird
elevator we go we go beat the the Boston
distro you know we see you know I'm
getting little antsy I'm looking at I'm
looking at watch you're looking at gene
we're like yo this is the time we're
like what's going on so we hide so
there's one of those moments when you
kind of see a person and you like they
make the eye contact is I get I got to
be Tim you're there so we go up and we
really had no prep man so shout out to
Marcia for getting everything set up you
know I'm saying Karen Wyse stuff like
that and we had a lot of let's just say
a special request that we'll put on us
you know as far as how it should be done
and your boy was nervous I go for the
first time I was like we started doing
and um you know once you started flowing
you know saying what's really cool and
it's definitely a moment I will remember
cuz I mean we all left but we like you
know did that just happen see me like
did that just happen
so did I want y'all perspective on the
Platinum join cuz that was mine like
that was a moment for me it was surreal
it was it was tensing with some
nervousness there's some weirdness blatt
the end of the day it was definitely
something I was like super proud that I
got a chance to experience with you so
Gina you start with you first like whoa
what about you two platinum
yeah well we were really learning about
everything they were doing while we were
at PAX or that week with that platinum
four and we found out really essentially
that week that they were gonna become a
publisher or we're gonna start
self-publishing so in and if you're if
you're a watt if your viewer publishers
do PR for their games if they are a
developer they don't really handle the
PR so when we went to talk to there was
no scalebound there was no bayonetta and
there was no babylons fall because they
are not the publisher of those games
they're developer so we were only
allowed to really talk about things that
they're publishing and when they made a
comment um you know we're glad to
we're glad to talk about or we're glad
to work on scalebound if Microsoft wants
us to or they need some comment to that
effect and then but they couldn't really
add to it and they wouldn't talk about
babylons fall they just said we're
working on it but something that's
really interesting is the Platinum four
right so it's wonderful 101 Kickstarter
it's the new studio in Tokyo and it's
project GG they have babylons fall in
the books that supposed to be coming at
this here and they have Bayonetta that
is up in the air what's gonna be really
interesting to see is what is gonna be
that for thing because I think that's
going to be telling about what's going
on with the other two but what about the
other two mmm
absolutely absolutely no macho make your
experience is the whole thing like
nerves dress like how'd you feel miss
plan yeah I mean well thanks to King for
just in putting those throw in the fire
interview skills because we thought of
it we thought interview question
beforehand we're talking about it seemed
like well we can ask and how we're gonna
ask it but really right there in the
spa's and that's it and if you kept
flowing cuz when I started thinking of
better questions yeah those are the ones
that were in the video but it was like
going into that room was just like wow
this actually happened that bro there's
definitely sweat dripping down my back
at home
for what I was doing it really felt like
cuz that was like one of our big
interviews on Saturday right it wasn't
really felt like Thursday and Friday
even that Wednesday night was the major
prep time for that Saturday interview
which was like our big hitter so it will
all of it was just amazing and then when
we finished it and we got our pictures
in that's almost like yes this is it
really did it we finally we finally made
well we're set out to do and
you mean knocked it out of the park
absolutely super proud of that I was
fantastic also what a shout out lost now
the great series where I daddy reminded
me that we had you know YouTube gaming
man it was really cool we got to be some
huge personalities um I believe uh Jake
Valentino was fantastic Lawrence I
Bobby's already got a chance to meet the
couple you know I'm saying also shots
about homie Jerome ASF he was in the
building you know saying old-school
style was with us for a couple of those
interviews huge youtubers that took the
time to sit there and talk to ILP give
us a loan Germany and I'm saying how
they got there I really enjoyed that
series I know Snell don't love therefore
the stream team so yeah man that was it
but for the most part man looks it was a
success a lot of work really a Georgia
support everybody gave us from the team
the away team everybody putting up the
articles dizzy undead John everybody
know everybody who contributed to the
whole movement man it was an absolute
success you know all the way across the
board super proud and um yeah we have we
had to try to sneak us some fun also as
well you know a shout to a gene for
putting us all into the potential party
cuz I was able to get some free food and
free drinks Oh Gigi no-neck cuz I needed
that one it was it was two nights - yeah
shout shout the bad [ __ ] shot the who
that ninja show the dead butch gobo Rena
voiceover oh shut up Roy Crafton then
you know they put together oh yes okay
good alright so it's some what play
craftsmen is and I hope you all remember
the old videos that we put up so just
going to our ol log they had in Boston
as well there was not as large scale as
it is in New York City but they had a
nice area and they had games there was
it what's the game of feral fox unfair
theory that is macho's very person to
you very much yes literally because he
thought it was a chill time pizza and a
drink and then
my brain is working 100% at a time and
I'm looking at I'm covering games and
I'm looking at games I don't go to these
conventions to to do nothing other than
highlight the great work from these devs
that need this light they need it
because this one dev on the fatal fury
Oh keep saying it wrong mom but that
game it was visually pleasing yes and
it's a two-man team one-man type of team
basically he's a carpenter in a day and
he's working on this game and it's his
passion but it looks so beautiful and
I'm like I can't wait for the game he
had to get picked up or come out but
these little shows are what helps and
ambush Cole is the CEO and he brings
this together and he can't get more
respect for me other than the fact that
he's my Skyward Sword brother was I
think was the balance gene you played
that right uh yeah you know I don't I'm
not sure if they even really have a name
yeah III don't remember but they're
using the Bluetooth connectivity to a
laptop to use the gyroscope and a phone
as controller and you can hold the phone
and use it as a controller or what they
did was they put it on a balance board
and it's like Marble Madness almost but
you're the you know and you're the ball
and you have to kind of you know balance
the board is good all mostly an exercise
game it was super cool and I hope
somebody picks that up yeah it was
really cool I was definitely definitely
feeling a lot of this stuff and again
shout the Lord Hyde was also with us
captured a lot of stuff for us but
that's what I got on pax that everybody
is good we could move on Oh Lord had it
is he still in the bushes is he back we
don't know yes I'm sleep Final Fantasy 7
you mean game of the years though stay
out of our car Buffy's very
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
anybody that it was you yeah like you
know salute the BG fuller cuz I was
doing an interview when I said like dirt
interview I see you about the corner of
my eye then I hit it with the value me
with the flower back during the
interview it's gotta fight really knew
that it's real smooth skills you know
the greatness Final Fantasy seven you
know a lot of people are like oh it's a
similar height that I had towards
Kingdom Hearts 3 you guys know you ain't
stopping this train wouldn't do nothing
for me I had to get a Playstation for
this game with the game you know Hector
gotta play that beta I was a little
jealous at that time so I I'm sleeping
the next morning and I'm saying I get
woke up Mikey by car dude he's like yo
the beta the demo has been dropped on
PlayStation I gotta go meet you I went
from oh my gosh man I'm tired - yo I got
it I gotta play this I got a buddies I
I've been doing a little bit of extra
work with like door - and stuff like
that I was like that's on hold all day
that's done I played that beta that did
that demo I don't know why key condors
baby because I've been playing so many
babies here lately I play that demo like
six times
mmm same bra same it's just it's taco
body I there is a couple things I want
to go into first off you know I'm gonna
talk last cuz I want to hear every one
all the other lures perspective first
thing I wanted your opinion on is how
many of these do you think they're gonna
have how many games second do you think
it's okay to release these in segments
as long as they really capitalize on the
gaming independently and let's go to be
Jesus
so the Final Fantasy demo you know was
Phi I play I played it three times and
that's something I can't remember the
last time I played any demo more than
facts more than once this there it's
been a while even since I played an
entire game more than once is just
something I typically don't do you know
a lot of games just haven't had that
effect on me lately you know I just you
know know how I'm feelin but you know
final fantasy that demo brought back
that like that childlike exciting where
you kind of wait back couldn't wait to
get back home and like you know that
that thing on music be cheeto I felt
like they got every character right like
when you're reading these back in the
nineties and you're hearing their voices
now like that's legit Lee how I felt
like they would sound oh yeah hey
Barrett I heard I heard Bears voice in
my air like in 97 and I'm like yo the
exact voice I heard he was always hyped
like that he always you know he had a
lot of dialogue all the time so that
means he was talking a lot yeah I
enjoyed it and everything was in capital
letters and you know yeah a whole bunch
of exclamation points so that's exactly
how I expected him to be you know and
the music the music surprised me only
because when they modernized a lot of
music and remakes it doesn't hit the
same fat right I think the dude
like I always I'm not evil to try to
pronounce his name he's the one that did
all the the remake for ten all the the
reanimated imaginated whoa
for some remediable yeah Watson that
dude knows what you doing he's a legend
he's a legend
yeah so I was surprised on like notice
this music still hey okay so it still
feel the same and then as far as the the
release I mean the original released in
like was afford this right it was yeah
cuz I had I had it on ps4 and I had to
uh I had it on PC Final Fantasy 8 was
for nine was for so was great so
soundtrack I just remember who brought
the collector's edition I think you get
the bonus soundtrack or something like
that with the Japanese version I always
sold it in a double pack yes the double
pack did yeah take it back but but when
they did it then that was for spacing
reasons right so because the game was so
big so I mean the fact that it's
stopping at Midgar makes me think it's
gonna be at least three because midgar's
like you was that maybe 20 25 30 percent
of the game mm-hmm something like that
a big chunk yeah you know it's not the
majority it's a little bit less the
majority you know a lot of let's be here
for those played the original when you
know that very part that part that we
played in the demo when the original
game was only like 15 minutes long yeah
yeah what would the character building
to met you know a slow-mo I don't
normally read non-color but I have mine
on colored glass about the Avalanche
crew like in the original Magesty was
not like she is now she all about her
some cloud like oh yeah she's trying to
get us work yeah so you know they really
built on the individual characters and
they use that foundation to make that
entire 15 minute you know fifteen minute
part of the game till like 45 minutes
throughout and it didn't feel like they
were doing it like adding extra for no
reason it felt like it was necessary to
have it yeah we do yeah so I mean I
guess it could be three disks I can't
see any reason it would be four but I
feel like they could I feel like they
could possibly put the rest of the game
on one more blue area but I don't know
if it's looking like that oh just this
one just this one part it's 100
gigabytes
I like all dead on one disc and and the
other disc out though how many games do
you think they'll have like parts of the
story from beginning to end I mean I
think you should shoot for two because
more than this yeah I mean I think it's
gonna be three but more than two people
like I'm gonna be like I brah okay we
gotta wait for the for the other part
like who okay like even though the each
part is gonna be like a full-fledged
game right like maybe like 30 40 hours
right that's that's cool and all but we
still gotta wait a whole nother year see
like and it was like as much as we like
you know event Avengers um you know the
park part one of it we still had to wait
so next April and like max I think that
kind of killed us I think we're looking
at a two year cycle for these games I
don't think wouldn't bother with you you
think she feels like a good skater in
two years I do you listen to the Xbox
versions next year
[Music]
the reason this game took so long
because they had to like okay at all
like what I don't think it's okay like I
understand like they they kind of don't
have a choice it's either this or we
wait like what maybe four more years for
the complete game exactly what do I do I
like it no I don't
but there's this time where you have to
be realistic it's gonna take four to
five you know like first off King with
you know the investor time you'll talk
to some a week we'll have a link we'll
have any money back for like five six
years they're gonna be like them make
another game you come from what I come
from income out it come out right that
one final fantasy when they showed that
back the first time they showed it right
well I'm in on Nintendo first and then
Nintendo Sony came in through that bag a
totally we got more space for you we can
get the artistic vision out mm-hmm music
that you want you can get these polygons
you can make it look way better then
whatever that ultra 64 was trying to
talk about with the $500 cartridge they
said we're gonna make no money there but
we're gonna make some money with these
CDs you know these deep this okay so
they did the switchover no we gonna give
it to you in chunks and pieces you know
why because they had to deliver a game
but isn't this day and age I just
listened to you guys just would fight
these people back and so another one
show bit pieces of game give me a
complete game cuz I don't want to get to
Midgard and gotta wait here years ago
here's what they could have done right
because if I remember this correctly
remember when this was revealed at e3
2002 thousand 15 right yes mm-hmm
didn't they say that the director of the
game had no idea he was the director of
the game the man found out he was
directing the game same time we did
macho no macho we're gonna do this
interview he's a bgt goat up in the
podcast y'all Victor Alice T he said
what if Square Enix decides to use this
for their own subscription service Wow
don't put no thoughts in their head I
don't like that they're splitting up in
games but you got to consider like the
mentality that Final Fantasy fans in
general you know seven eight even my
favorite game but we've been asking for
this game for like 15 years and you can
wait 217 my life tomorrow
teto all right I'm playing the first
part this is going to pave the way for
more crap of this type of nature so you
okay you're saying that this is a
dangerous precedent set that if we don't
fight square edicts that this can set
the chin for other people for mass
effect for other people doing things
craziness listen I'm telling you people
right now do not buy this game bad you I
don't care how bad we needed food not
buy this game make them give you the
complete game when you go buy the game
buy all of this in one shot when you
suffer off on an end of the game already
[Laughter]
PlayStation when Playstation got the
game it was a big cool that's a big deal
for what they're trying to do started
coming out and to your games and and you
take this stuff right now you're gonna
get piecemeal joke games for the rest of
your damn life
don't take this right now they ride it
with cake they rot everything I gotta
get I gotta get low G let's start you
first like the demo your experience it
did obviously this whole bit about be
episodic any parts well I was really
have said there was of a sonic but I
think the alternative is the game gets
cancelled or doesn't get made with all
the development issues that they had and
what was what's annoying to me is on the
box art or the box art that's out there
right now I don't know what it's gonna
look like when it comes out in a month
it says it's got the exclusive to
PlayStation 1 year or played first on
PlayStation will go on the box but
unaware and the packaging does they say
anything about being part one so
wouldn't they coming Homer to Final
Fantasy 7 part 2 and then are they gonna
collect it Jason fryer had asked the
producer how many parts it was gonna be
and he said I don't know maybe five whoa
Wow whoa
so what
they're all my 250 joint just went out
the window I gotta get you it because I
saw the Twitter streets it shut the bags
in the trash I know there was some
back-and-forth there to it you had Final
Fantasy 7 you know fans it's it's a
contentious topic so first about the
demo your feeling about it and then
about the episodic aspect yeah so the
demo is awesome it's what I want it
wrong 587 remake the exam point voice
acting is top-notch hmm the gameplay is
just amazing - a lot of people haven't
really famous everyone talked about the
gameplay of it was just like a mix of
old and new and it's perfect it's it
it's polished - at the same time a
little bit more polished when it comes
out but you know it is what it is yeah
so with the whole situation with it
being splinter parts yeah there's
initial worrisome how they gonna do this
what's gonna be split up
you know what's the complete experience
but from what Square Enix reps are
saying we're in the dev team saying this
is gonna be a complete game you're gonna
get that complete experience and with
the story 587 how being split into parts
and there's definitely has different
flavors throughout the entire game so a
big sense say if they won't split up the
story okay look we are definitely
fanboys at this but we're not gonna act
like this is the same game because it's
not okay what you were saying I saw it
in your eyes we got interviews to do to
use like a bra I have Final Fantasy to
go to and come hell or high water you're
not stopping me taking any of your words
right
yeah you know if they want to break it
up cuz there's different flavors it was
same flavor it's a different beast
you ain't even played the demo so you
even know the difference you look if you
if you it's free how is that not what
I'm not supporting what they do all
right all right King all right it's a
different beast man there it's not like
they're just taking the same they're
putting new aspects in this game that
was never in the original there's a
first-class soldier that was never in
Final Fantasy something that's in this
game they have a completely new enemy on
here called The Darkness or whatever
they're called that it's like the little
ghost black beans that just roll around
no one knows what that is
it's not like this is the original game
cause it's not this is yo this is
different right the shadows lay we got
different enemies is different
everything so you is warranted that you
pay $300 in parts to get this this is me
you I just want to know when women's are
gonna stop because I don't want this to
permeate into games I like way over the
same if Microsoft tells me because y'all
willingness take this and they didn't
the talking heads up in the day as
getting that money it's because I think
reefer game at this the the amount the
popularity 5 in c7 only final fantasy
can do this mmm right I mean it's such a
it's such a big global name throughout
the world but I mean getting or getting
off of that it's just it's the pimping
splinter parts it's yeah it sucks and I
like that first either I still don't
like that but again it's a story in the
game during characters give me great
gameplay for every entry and you're good
it's a genes point - with 557 remake it
at the Box are not saying part one I
mean if if we're to get real on this one
I think that there it could not have
this description service but I have an
expansion upon that initial release
there's nothing similar to 584 team of
shadow bringers every expansion is $40
to add to the game so that's why I think
that they're probably going to do they
haven't said anything about that same
[Music]
joke but I see nothing but a downfall
for us as gamers we have a problem with
I don't want BG's a thought on this part
because I'm only only reason why I'm
asking him because I saw his video and
he came from objective side and it
wasn't sounding like a fan because a lot
of these videos I thought was fanboy
videos right so his objective question
is this right do you think this is the
tipping point because sometimes they
need a game that is such a juggernaut is
such a force like like fortnight may
Sony bend the knee it needs a game of
this magnitude that has a family they
know y'all are there and yet they know
you want it is this the game to push
games into that monetize type of
sectional thing like you get this level
for this price you get this rubbish
again you know and it is this going to
start what if they did that to you
excuse enrage you get part too late
you know that mean to push us in that
dangerous area so don't think this will
become a trend because one once again
not defending them but we're square
they have like justification that they
could actually use like plausible
deniability for someone who says this is
just this is you cashing in they can
actually say this game is legit huge and
it's like forty hours not ever even most
most games that come out or not like 40
plus hours most are in like the twenty
hour range you have no reason to split
up a a game in that tolls twenty hours
you can't at least a five-hour game on a
disk each time so that that's that's not
gonna fly
mom what was your question again our
early for my mom is just is just a
tipping point so it's the precedent
this step is this because maybe one shoe
or see it this is just my thing when we
got all those blue crates and you know
government's has to step in and has them
you know cut stuff down and have to put
laws to protect us from ourselves
because if if the world would have stood
up and said oh hell no we're not taking
no episodic crap do you think they'd go
back and give you the full game later
because I can see them doing the full
game now let me ask Kim is what what is
the difference between what they're
doing with this in comparison to the
telltale model that we accepted which
had less hours right there Walking
Dead's the the wolf among us and they
say hey you won't wait now it wasn't
like a year no doubt the length of time
wasn't this yeah but they put that up
and gamers didn't really seem to have
too much of a problem with what happened
to tell to what a financially my point
is that what did you say to what might
be G's point with the part one the
episodic part actually be holding that
doesn't help me yeah the thing about
telltale games is they were
meant to be literal like episodes sure
you know where they were meant to like
run like a TV show so that's why what
we're fine with it the other thing is
who I don't think you should become a
trend is this kind of stifles developers
from moving on to other projects if they
have to focus on something into three
places like I don't think funny dog is
really gonna like let's say was the Last
of Us part if they want to make Last of
Us part two but it had like three
different parts left last it was part
two point two two point six two point
eight they gotta like focus on that as
big as the studio isn't as much of a
mole task I don't think that it takes
work to milk square its finessing you
shout out the air in g94 to awesome chat
they said part one is sixty hours and
then JD gamer twenty hours which a
PlayStation over here promoting selling
pieces of games it started with the last
of us with no multiplayer and now it's
spread the Final Fantasy 7 what's next
in pockets you know what I would laugh
if they just rollin everybody in the
whole game is in there I mean we're
talking last night
I honestly have no clue what's in this
game where this game ends because you
don't fight your Nova - you're on the
ship going to leave injunction and
Genova is a boss in this game really you
know say red stuff in it you don't meet
him they said you don't play as you you
don't play as him you know usually I use
them yeah you say that they say that
they uh in order to implement like his
character arc where this is son like
that but he comes in so late and in this
in this iteration of the game that it
might as well not be me play upon
because you know they are changing some
things digital I already have multiple
boss fights or was it just what
wasn't no hurting the very first time
you fought Genova was on the ship leave
injunction right yeah and I was way past
but they even said Sephiroth is earlier
if you see him earlier in this game yeah
we're the first time you see Sephiroth
is on that ship going to Junction yeah
and I think I think it's worse because
everyone knows who's Sephiroth is he's
such a big factor how can you have this
game and not have sefirot though I think
it's more ease or anything crazy just
listening to y'all talk about this right
cuz I played the game right and I did
these things but y'all got down to the
little my new shirt
cuz you remember when we went to
junction last time I played no I
downloaded them I have now I can
understand the fans not caring how long
it takes for the game to come out but I
mean you know the way squared takes
their time with stuff like let's be
honest right let's say this is for
installment you could literally be
looking at this game spanning three
generations of console go free
that's my cursor yes that's kind of nuts
I don't you know whatever but that's
kind of nuts now for me like it's the
new people coming in right because this
is a game just bias looks alone is gonna
draw people in so the thing is now now
you have you have to make sure that each
one of these games ends on a note that
is acceptable as a full-on game for
somebody coming into a brand-new
that's my next question on what a
speed-up I think the only people that
can really answer this is me incognito
don't know how much you remember King
look there's only sections in this game
that I would feel be acceptable to end
it for instance in the trailer they show
Sephiroth going through fire that's
there's only one part time that ever
happens in the game and that's the
flashback where he's burning clouds
village down
Eston like Beth when he pulled me behind
all right that yeah to me is just new
people coming in they're probably gonna
want to play this game you need to be
honest but again if it doesn't
necessarily matter if you finish each
one on a note that is not like a
cliffhanger it has to be jumping off the
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
eye so shout-out to JD gamer final check
if we allowed the Saudis the Sony Alec
high cause but to do this it will every
other just like the Michael transaction
will be played three or four one
freaking game shout the victory listing
to us super chat square enix charge you
for Kingdom Hearts 1.5 and two points
you know that Achilles my boy bed
he said Gabrus you don't stand for fall
first off yeah you know obviously for me
but I think about ps1 the games that are
synonymous is the ridge races that the
techeuns for graphical fidelity but as a
lot of Final Fantasy 6 what fans will
accurately say 7 is what brought it to
the masses 7 was a movie you've never
seen anything like that just the Silicon
Graphics cities the the background the
polygons at that time it was the
pinnacle of graphical fidelity and y'all
can't front when y'all saw video and I
saw a summon for the first yeah
when you saw the Leviathans night sort
of round all that fly you know her it
periphery would you say like it games
were doing something at that time we
never see one so it's going to be an
emotional thing for games too too much
into the whole you know what's better
than 6 or 7 because 7 had that gift of
I'm the first 3d one No
step 7 children first one to that also
had the controversy with it yes is in
topi
yeah it was the way to marketed the game
he marketed as an action game so right
will purchase the game for the kids and
they went homes like what the hell is
this crap
we have burn baby yeah we've had many
people with ILP as guests say like that
was their first RPG like like Kayla say
like they did that was an introduction
so let's get that out the way here's my
thing it's near and dear to my heart
I am super critical when something's on
my Mount Rushmore right when sometimes
on my Mount Rushmore and you gonna
remake it or reimagine or whatever you
playing around with it I'm already
looking at you with the Quan I like Pham
don't mess up the Mona Lisa you know I'm
saying so when I booted the joint up I'm
not gonna front like I was nervous I
said let me see how they do them I'm a
king down pull off the train we both
took the same screenshot to chase we
shot one PS now and then the music kick
and I'm right here this is it they feel
they got the the music is such a
nostalgic piece right that's one thing
graphic fidelity then they reimagine
what the modernist of the combat system
and let me tell you y'all know I don't
ride for remakes I don't ride from I
have a strict sense that no remade game
could be gaming it right this is a demo
but I'm gonna tell you right now I'm
teetering like what I've seen at this
demo is so impressive that I'm like yo
me because I trust me I still gonna
stand tall and say no remake can make it
but this is the first time I'm like yo
don't feel bad difference on this feelin
significant duals is like fully fledged
like like its its crib in the thing that
won it for me personally and I know I'm
family but when you fight when you start
to fight it you got cloud right and you
he feels like slow methodical
he switches to that what's that stance
I'm actor that the jointing up Sam
Rocko my whole thing is when he plays
completely different right so that's the
first it then the second thing is I get
buried in the party and he cloudcare do
dudes that the little satellite digs up
in the end so I had to switch to Barrett
for the more way so they literally made
completely different archetype
characters that reimagined like one was
Lord this is one was this then the
banter between the characters like you
you switch him and you may know bears mo
now you need my do I agree with the
practice of milking a franchise no right
here's the thing the fact that it is
really I'm just saying guys you can't
stop the gamers gonna have to stand up
with a wallet and say no we are not
gonna do it so every town even with
micro-church axes all this stuff we
complain about what is it happy dude go
straight over to the slot machine they
say they ain't buy what cuz if that was
the case why would these companies do it
because there's finances they see it I'm
not condoning it I'm just telling you
that gamers oh wait we talk strong we
talk like we go we gonna rise against
the Machine and dawn soon as that
released a drop who therefore they will
Alex Wow you know from presto look like
he was completely like ie by this but I
see him a little bit coming off play
that demo he was like mmm it's actually
pretty crispy I don't agree with what
they're doing but I've been asking for
this for so they can say yo we decided
$60 is not if we're not asking for $120
what attic is doing to you okay now this
is a problem for the chat can you say we
put all this that we fir bro you the
same person buying Ark DLC you support
that game to hate more are drug of
choice let's get our drug piece at your
point where you just say if this game is
a hundred and twenty dollars how much
you gotta calm down
[Laughter]
if it was sold out everywhere I'm going
on eBay and buying one for 200 like this
I think it feels like when you're
looking at this thing you just watch on
YouTube or you hold you play you're like
alright cool this looks okay when you
play it it's a whole different ball do
your drug apiece Beto's is boss to the
final question for BG interested check
this game have a chance to get nominated
for game of the year it should it win
game with you know is only a part of a
game weird because it will be very weird
and then seems unfair that like other
developers who are making you know an
entire game right ok so I release my one
game you know that I released every
three four years and for game of the
year there's gonna release let's say its
yearly you're gonna release a game two
thousand twenty twenty-one twenty-two
but you have three chances three years
in a row a kid it came I don't know how
you like do that are they gonna like
like oh now but part two is it's this
look weird and like I can understand why
they got a par five in like 20 years
game of the year last year I was you
could I was one of those people man I
was like Resident Evil 2 does not
deserve being nominated
oh come let me let me finish let me
finish
BG I was like it does not but this year
more than only because it's good that
Bay he'll do anything is giving us the
same content of you can compare Final
Fantasy to destiny right and some
ongoing positioning game right but but
we got to let that rock cuz he makes my
point
don't mention what a shame continued
support
but matter is this right yeah we already
accept all this paywalls and all this
little paid portions because when they
come out with season passes I get really
upset and I have to continue to pay to
get something I just did it again in the
division right come out with the king of
the New York division and now you give
me twenty nine ninety five cuz I wanna
play hot monkeys loving my god he's over
there my guy is worth twenty nine ninety
five so I'm gonna go over there and I'm
gonna play with him I can't play this is
the thing with you it's in 29.95 if it's
set fifty nine my guy is gonna have to
miss me complete purchase okay you
you're you just said you're willing to
go to 120 bucks per game you are willing
to do whatever it takes to get this game
so if you're willing to do whatever it
takes why don't you eat willing to wait
a few years to get the complete game two
years play game and the demo has your
demo doesn't have some issue I mean
listen I already I almost never
pre-order games already got the digital
edition super daddy fat stacks at it you
talkin crazy right now
i'ma need you to sit down in that corner
headbutt yourself in the chest and think
about you know what hi Daddy
I will do all of that but with my right
hand I will be ordering the collector's
edition
my homie pixel [ __ ] files we say yo
keep it real mad I've been putting the
same game out with my two tix for a
decade we've seen this bottle before
squared it started plays yeah that's
what I wrote let's go let's get some
hashtags blame EA in that chats railroad
our old pics of it thank you for
justifying my foolishness Thank You Def
Sega - I suggest we got everyone out
here walking like a pig rid oh we got a
boy this would never it is a very
contentious topic is we understand both
sides absolutely flat do these last two
really quick as I know it's a long shot
but alright so real quick y'all ghost I
say I like a Attic sakushima just like
just make believe the t's now let me
pronounce the way I want to pronounce it
sushi
moving along we've got to release they
are June 26th
trailer looks fire I've got a bunch of
editions announced you got the deluxe
edition special edition collector's
edition we finally got a release date so
I want to bring this to the realm but
actually in a bigger fashion so looking
at the 2020 lineup for a Playstation 4
right now so look at it we got March to
June and moss we got neo to an MLB the
show April we got the Final Fantasy 7 go
remake in April came a year last of us
part to banger return
June ghostess is shima so this lineup is
pretty impressive and I want to bring
this to the room you know in reference
to the PlayStation 4 ending the
generation and I wanted to ask the round
is it sacrilegious to say that the
PlayStation 4 has the go end of a
generation release software cycle so we
go go real quickly let's get a dick
jumping off then we get to guess so add
with this Lana how do you feel is this
the greatest ever end of a generation to
a console I feel like you know last you
Lucas spooky first Sony you like really
bad but they got you know maybe four
months of Game of the Year contenders
and you can't take that no that's okay
Atticus cosine B G is this sacrilegious
to say that this software lineup is the
goal of the generation 2 nd generation I
don't remember every end of generation I
got terrible memory but um remember I
don't I don't think it I don't think
it's like the best of any you know
generation I don't think so
ok ok if you can if you can recall
anything that any console generation
ending its without y'all I can't show
you one that's better but I don't think
this one is like that great just by
itself just don't know how things that
great I mean ok it was out so there's
ghosts of sushi mothers who I don't see
Neos and last of us like a dreams of our
that's trash right you got predator -
you got Iron Man you go yeah you got
Yakuza like a dragon
ok let me let me let me break all those
bars off let me go
I have to break might have to write down
a list okay so yaku you said Yakuza yeah
mm-hmm
which one is that zero negative one this
is the RP the one that plays like a
turn-based RPG so no way does that even
have a US release date yet does it so we
can scratch it off the list okay
the last of us little I love the last of
us but it's it's missing a multiplayer
so yeah it gets knocked off a few point
moving on to neo neo 2 listen
I put like 80 hours in the original
right okay an action mode on the on a
PlayStation console even pro that game
looks disgusting looks horrible because
they in action mode I think it ran
between like 900 900 feet let alone a
pro and and it wasn't locked there was a
whole lot of checkerboarding that
matters but like what a game that I put
in 80 hours I had to look at those
disgusting visuals all waiting for I'm
probably waiting for the PC version
which I never do so that's the last of
us and he'll do it what else ghosts it's
just kind of trashed right now because
it's it's G this crying inside they have
improved hardware to support like you
know the the
consistent frame rates and refresh and
refresh rate and you don't have to have
you know cerebro on your head with all
these wires yo I'm done with you the
artists trash so okay so he doesn't rip
through your whole list leave ghost is
the only one I have nothing bad to say
about here so let's get Lord Jean who is
cringing during the VR SEC but you got
bet is dis line up the goat n
degeneration well off the top of my head
I can't think of anything that's really
that great my brain immediately goes to
the original Xbox last year I feel like
half-life 2 was one of the game's doom
three rallies for challenge mech assault
- I don't think halo - but hey let's who
came out within the last 12 months of
the original Xbox the original Xbox had
a really good final year yeah I can't
think maybe the Super Nintendo had a
really good last year but this is
amazing six months Sony's gonna have I'm
really excited for Ironman that not only
could so it hasn't a lot to be excited
about for psvr since blood and truth
came out last summer I'm really excited
for predator we played predator that
game is phenomenal it looks amazing I
have never played the multiplayer The
Last of Us I really I have and I'm
excited for you who so later this year
so it was good so so it U is your gut
telling put your spot G yes your gut
saying though that you're leaning
towards this maybe or your gut same me
maybe other generations may have had it
at better end of a generation I
depending on what the new consoles
launch with and I think that's a
completely different story and come like
September when we're looking back on the
year that Sony had and
we start the game of the year
conversation I think a lot of the people
that are gonna have those conversations
go oh my god this year that Sony had it
go Tsushima can do what we think it's
gonna do and the Last of Us 2 lives up
to the height you're gonna you're gonna
be looking back and maybe like they're
gonna have four games in the game of the
Year category you know that maybe three
games in my opinion we have to see what
Nintendo is gonna do - but if Nintendo
it doesn't worry apply you know I think
come December we're gonna be looking
back in a while they had a pretty crazy
here no doubt Lord
macho Final Fantasy 7 remake sit me just
but you know as far as the software is
this goat no I think it could be
stronger I think it does a stronger
we're again we're coming up on the
next-gen console so that's the new hype
right now but a lot of people are saying
another beginning of the year that we're
hungry we want these games when these
museums coming and they're coming
they're coming they're definitely has
something for everybody but I still
think there's gonna be some people out
there just and say it it's not for me
we're worried for next-gen that's that's
next step next-gen is where it's gonna
be yeah and uh it's really gonna come
with these new IPs as well
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we play we playing favorites here at
lords of gaming that I'm now I'm high in
the bush and size heals reviews I'm not
a lie that sucker punch disrespect ok
fair enough
Lord solve is this the go-to ended
generation and Moby the shows it yeah
but just look at first party stuff right
you think about it is like when you when
you look at third party in addition to
first party there might be other years
and end of cycles that kind of look
comparable or better just because the
vast majority gives you an a half when
you just look at first party stuff most
first parties are definitely thinking
forward right but now with this thinking
now that things are kind of cross
generational and everything is sort of
fluid and the expectation or what they
said is that ps4 games will be playable
on PS 5 I think it doesn't matter to
them for the heart stop to it so I mean
to have this many first party titles
coming out in the final that in the
final year before new console launches
is crazy and a potential and and i'ma
put Final Fantasy 7 in there because we
could feel how we feel right about
whether it should be game of your
nominee or not what its gonna be there
you gonna tell me it's not gonna be in
the Keeley's I don't agree with that
even for posterity sake it's gonna be
there right
Genesis I three games that could be it
you know kind of pecking at that that
that panders that 10 you know
masterpiece perfect score type thing
yeah from I've never seen it from a
first party like this ever let I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say that so I'm excited I
mean I love less of us I'm more excited
for Ghost of Tsushima Wow never tell you
why yeah you do
like the whole story about it is that is
a samurai in the samurai way yes to
utilize ninja tactics which is like
happen like a samurai idealistic Lee
opposed to ninja now don't report evil
fast we want to know what broke him I
wanna know what broke him super
interesting like I really want to see
what happens at Last of Us mm-hmm I'm
I'm a little afraid that it doesn't do
the naughty cops the game's gonna be bad
it's just it's gonna be almost
impossible to live up to its predecessor
exactly I felt the same way I feel oh
let me get to before we hit King's
Landing um grazi mm check this is a
great end yes probably the best ever
Victor Alice being too loud a super chat
problem is the multi packs trumped the
PlayStation 4 exclusive Christopher hot
out here
Sony is making y'all been denis davidov
year is saudis and i want to read their
single read this he's not talking about
kind of sorry the other half in the
regular voice Sonny wants games out so
they can reveal garbage sparks line up
wow the disrespect
the disrespect so no I kick he heard you
Gretton and rolling you can make your
point quick and then we can move on well
you know Selleck said it so eloquently
as you can broke down your dreams and
your hopes Oh what caught was gonna
happen
i'ma say this right i'ma say the
question is is this this the greatest
end of console lineup I think this is
the greatest launch lineup for the
PlayStation 5 the same exact games it is
launch lineup that you're gonna pay
twice for but to be real I'm definitely
buying go sister Shima
I'm definitely mine The Last of Us - I'm
not buying are you man throw that in the
bushes definitely no I'm not no he
stayed on the square you know
I'm not getting cuz I'm gonna get it
from my xbox I'm gonna come out next
year and I'm gonna sit down I'm aware I
waited 15 years ago me 16 no no no no no
it has everything to do with no I'm not
dumb if you're not gonna support this
what bite on the Xbox no no no no no I
probably won't have to buy it probably
being game passes um does coming game
pass low imma blow up the internet that
BRE I gotta take a stance against that
game and you have to take a stance on
the honor pride on the practices that
they pushing forward I'm sorry I I just
see this as a tipping point I'm pissed
off with season passes and battle passes
and all this crap I'm used to games
coming out full so and their season I
think this is probably a really good
launch ending of a lineup for the places
I'm so happy that they do have games
because they gave you a year of nothing
just last year so and it gave me dreams
this year was like your hair this is
what's up and you know dudes is not
really into it some dudes is on YouTube
making videos of remakes of games of
games of games but I mean it's a nice
utensil but I think they aren't
something at the end they held you back
they held back games if they could have
put out a year ago or you know to give
you this lineup so they can give you the
same lineup for the PlayStation 5 but
for the PlayStation 4 if you own a
Playstation 4 you and utopia you might
not even have to make the jump because
for a whole year you're gonna be playing
the same games on the PlayStation I'm
actually surprised impressed with it uh
you actually think this line it was
somewhat impressive no it's very
impressive it's very impressive if
you're looking at the competition I mean
I'm not gonna sit there and say
Microsoft Azure swinging stuff out the
park
no Microsoft is setting up the next
generation you know but police station
is ending their generation so they you
know they're gonna be ended in the next
generations over there mighty big yeah
I'll be honest it's not until
I looked at the line I mean you've you
you physically look at it and I was just
like man like that's pretty impressive
out there's a disclaimer right these
games gotta be ready they they have to
live up to expectation but as of right
now on paper if you look at it
nice can't think of anything more
impressive the jury is gonna be out
though obviously neo2 you know you don't
we don't have the list of every console
generation ending right one of us to
compare notes but what I can say is
being a we're prisoners of the moment
right this looks really good looking
really good cuz I mean like I said you
got Final Fantasy 7 remake in itself
already with the hype and is generating
right go see to see me this super
promising new IP that people are very
excited about Last of Us - arguably is
Last of Us is arguably the goal for a
lot of gamers and this is the sequel
so again pure potential right and there
Neil is not no slouch just by I know BG
waiting on a resolution you know is it's
it's a beloved game and I'll be the show
sorrows me this is the last year they'll
have it to yourself you know say but
pressings early on but it's super
impressive it's super impressive the
jury's out I think this is really really
explosive and I just got to see if they
may hit expectation but that's all I got
on Philly Eagle fire obviously which a
news flash to the boys both blue and
green us gamers have all consoles not
liking a game has nothing to do with
plastic
it's simply preference I feel that so
soft real quick is III what's going on
man
yeah man I just say yeah I hate to be
the the pragmatist in the in the realist
but I don't like this is spooky to me
man on our la la County has declared a
state of emergency because of the
carnivorous and we go garlic whatever a
city what became a joke on the podcast
after news so a carnivorous
the king has coined that yes 4d
monetization purposes
you know even even even YouTube must
bend a knee to the king what's funny is
VG's calling the TV I like that
LA County is in the state of emergency
now decided part of the country New York
State is the carrick state of emergency
sold question is does III get cancelled
got something you wanna hear and then
there was some comments at Easton
stridor made just about if that does
happen I I can't guarantee you but
high-percentage
III will never show back up and now that
was the opinion he had he's like well if
you force these people to have to do
it's just not just because of this is
because of them linking information it's
because of people keep pulling out like
ESA is gonna do everything in their
power to not let this I think it's
Cassie because I have a feeling they
know it's gonna do humor number on them
and yeah and that's even beyond this
stuff right this did this carnivorous
stuff mm-hmm fact that I am a bit
recently pulled out up sort of
organizing the entire event and again it
goes back to what he was saying about
I'm not like in the direction when in
charge the people who set to put the
show on are not liking it but let me let
me actually yourself do you think that
that that moved that guy leave it
do you think that's separate from the
whole epidemic it out of Nevada got when
he was like he's totally separate but
you're like a directional thing right
it's once again like you said it's a
directional thing I'm not feeling the
direction and so it brings in the
question how many people how many more
people a use this this this carnivorous
thing as a as a second Sara Lee
criticize the direction and be and use
this as an excuse to get out right
wait and how many other people do pull
out because of the direction they're not
feeling right so it goes things like
they're being attacked from both ends
they kind of been stuck in the middle
and so it does it's kind of a lose-lose
situation right if this if this safety
concern is health concern causes them to
shut down they're in trouble if for
whatever reason the event is trashed
because nobody everybody's pulling out
mm-hmm
they're in trouble so it feels like a
lose-lose situation like I said like if
it's canceled for whatever reason maybe
right mm mm I don't know that it ever
comes back
mm good question that's a good question
let's get a let's get our lord at Hector
low cheating real quick what do you feel
I mean is it in trouble do you think
it's still a chance for it to go forward
or any way you can jump in I was gonna
say is I think that there is definitely
something else is going on if you look
at you look at Rebecca Valentine on
Twitter I no doubt yoga bro they seem to
be alluding to this other thing going on
with I am a bit on top of the medical or
health concerns that there's something
going on behind the scenes then you have
the issues with Sony not being there and
other publishers drop out and I really
think that's something to watch out for
is gonna be how Ubisoft reacts if
they're gonna be there or not because I
feel like Ubisoft in Nintendo or the
last two shoes to fall in terms of what
they do and Ubisoft as they seem to be
really counting on e3 and how they're
going to align what they do going
through the next year because you be
stuff still has four games to release in
the next fiscal four or five games to
release the next fiscal quarter we don't
have dates for any of them right no it's
a good point no matter what solver but
it did Ubisoft thing right I do think
just like Microsoft they pride
themselves I'm having a big presence at
e3 but I think they don't necessarily
need it to be there and they go all out
right sometimes the conference's are a
little wacky or whatever the case may be
but they really go in and they I know
they love being there I know they love
that sort of interaction and to bring
out their new stuff I just if they if
they
step back from it though and they're
forced to step back from it they seem
like a publisher to me that doesn't need
it the strength of knowing that you're
gonna get a new AC that Legion is
finally gonna come out they're gonna
announce whatever new stuff is coming um
I don't think they need it well it was
mainly designed for the industry the
media the influencers that's what it was
designed for is designed for a common
middle grace plan a middle ground place
where people could come look at the
inner uh look at the products that
they're doing you know and then properly
be able to write about it and cover it
but I think people don't realize if III
leaves it's it's gonna put it it's gonna
put a huge day in the industry because
we no longer have that well I mean yeah
this is Toby get a little macho and then
we'll jump in will man I completely
agree with with Alex point of view of
that it's such a huge event that goes on
throughout the earth throughout the one
time in the year for not only publishers
developers but for media as well so
taking that away from everybody's he
says in creating a huge is dead and that
and with coronavirus and everything's
going with carnivorous and just the
leaks themselves I think just a bump in
the road right now for e3 and they're
gonna get back on track cause right now
they're in desperate mode so they're
guys to pull out the big guns on this
one now yeah we started off at ik you
got in King did you get off no I didn't
I think people would agendas is moving
in a way I think people with their their
agenda for their platform and for their
things are doing things in their fashion
I said the first time when individuals
left III I didn't care anyway because I
didn't go to your function and it's not
as no there's no slight towards you it's
isn't that about you brother
um it's about the the what III
represented to me as a child so the fact
that I'm able to get there able to go
there I don't really care about your
agenda I don't really care about what
you how you feel that you should control
it yeah as as youth we always feel that
we can do better than ours if our elders
right so we're gonna look at III as the
elders and then the youth are the
influencers or the people that were
involved that had a voice that were
growing and they got bigger so they felt
in their heart and then III and they're
able to challenge III now the fact that
the leaks went on not too long ago with
their information being put to the
streets they looked at Big Brother and
said you did us dirty and we're gonna
get you back so now you have all these
little silent protesting because they
can't come out and tell you that they
actually protest them they can't come
out and tell you that we're actually
making a move against them and I think
they're using the carnivorous virus as a
vehicle to push their agenda to get you
to think in a manner see you because
once you control mind [ __ ] and you
control populace once your control
populace and you can have them move in
the manner that you want them to
I don't believe eat three is gonna be
touched because why wouldn't pacts be
touch why wouldn't pacts be canceled the
reason why pacts wouldn't be canceled
because it's not on the agenda of those
individuals because they trying to act
like they're standing up for the little
guy
they're only standing up for themselves
all right so don't think that it because
III is in a situation where it's a state
of emergency
you listen it's a state of emergency
every flu season the fluid and killed
more people than any carnivorous can and
I want y'all to stop drinking a tea I
want you to look and see what's going on
in front of your eyes these people have
an agenda against this party yeah you
think you think it's Bor against what
clarify your stance you think it's more
because of what kind of like that got at
left I saw was talking about where it's
a philosophy change I so Lee said they
didn't like the direction Geoff Keighley
said it in like right you know
this is all that and that the I'm just
trying to get your point that this is
water and that the carnivorous right now
should be name is smokescreen to just
that's mostly but they're using that to
be the old well the reason why used that
to not go to packs there was no reason
for Sony not to be a patch it was no
reason for Capcom not to be a pest what
about you know we see an events like
South by Southwest guess who I mean okay
well I just want like what what's your
response to these other events that may
not necessarily gain that's also take
different communica could communica type
of thing they can never control they can
never control that alright okay but this
can actually be maintained and
controlled but there was turning it into
what what what I perceived that eating
he said they was going to do they was
gonna make it more palatable to the
crowd right so just the influencers have
a whole different philosophy change
remember what sovereign said and what
addicts said addicts said III was never
meant for you and III was always meant
for the developers and for bigger
companies to meet in a common place to
talk about what's going forward and for
y'all guys to get a peek in when they do
the shows they send it out to you to see
it so you can envy
there's no more envy if you can attend
mmm if it's open for everybody so
elitist don't you feel elite if they if
the commoner is there which is which is
with okay get at it the majority people
always seem complaining about this was
the people that's going to these was the
media was the huge because they had a
waiting line that was eateries right
because III never never came up with a
real plan of how how do you appease
meteorite and let
do the job right and we're you know
loads of gaming and I and and I appeal
probably in that boat this year right
how do you media and then how do you
start a piece letting in and they never
they had to this point haven't figured
that out in a way that I think movement
in the right direction that's absent
right but but it took King's point you
know maybe is too little too late the
damage has already been done because of
the last two years let's be honest we
there's some truth to again say in a
sense of you know media not being happy
with integrating with the concert
credits being online remember that first
time they opened it up to the fans right
and they allowed the fans to pay a
certain amount price like 150 or
whatever and you know you can get in it
those guys look kind of the same line as
the you know the idea is that whoever
the game stops whatever and it was a big
push back it was a thickness is very
upset with that is there's people on the
mic is this better cuz I was like
sitting way back in my chair okay it's
all good he's on better yeah he said you
sound lower yeah now you sit back but
yeah I mean I understand you were saying
solve it okay about one thing is this
right to end my point is people agendas
okay and it has absolutely nothing to do
with III falling out it's it's I'll show
you I'm going to teach you and it's a
group of them it's a group of them and
they are very vocal and they have a
large influence and they're controlling
your thoughts and yet in your thoughts
is oh man III is going down it's just a
death knell it's the death knell if you
hear something over and over and over
again you tend to believe it you tend to
believe that it's the truth
if you every time you turn around is
another video saying is this the death
knell now I'm gonna give you one caveat
okay I already paid for my flight in my
mind I'm so I'm completely biases the
hell no
let's go in the bread is out there we
hunted the place rented the flight is
painful
who is ready to go yes alright I'm ready
to get this coverage for you the same
way that I went over to the packs for
the car never I'm willing to move but
you like black couple of fears that that
a couple of other functions that we
attend might be canceled because of the
carnivorous I believe because I believe
that the insurance rates that went
through the roof there's other things in
the background it goes along with stuff
but do I think that III is dead I don't
think so I think it's an evolution stage
and the people that was from the old
regime doesn't like the new direction
it's an interesting thing I mean I'm not
I'm not some parts of what you say I
definitely do give support would you say
look um with this whole thing man you
know you you you definitely obviously
concern my whole thing forget all that
that bar thing honestly is the LA aspect
the state of emergency aspect right that
part concerns me because I don't know if
they're the state of emergency as well
right labem right and and I just don't
want to minimize it though my my whole
thing is I just want hopefully that they
get that under control right and whether
it be having the proper arm testing or
recognition things that they need to be
able to handle something like this right
so I don't want to minimize that cuz yes
there are also you know people die and
stuff like that I'm not trying to
minimize that just for gaming at the end
of the day if that does get lifted you
know I'm saying and they're able to to
show that they can you know I would say
containing but hold it at the end of the
day we got to see how this thing gonna
play out it's fluid that's now I look at
it this thing is a fluid situation we'll
see we went to three months away hottest
thing plays out you know I mean I would
hate it for it to be canceled and
selfishly like yeah we we've already
made plans to go out there and we trying
to give coverage stuff like that we know
Microsoft had the intention of me and
they obviously with GDC they pulling out
you know how it would be a shame
obviously as a result of this thing for
them to pull out because you know
Microsoft tends to do big and let's
that's a console watch as gamers I think
it will sad in us I think that we
wouldn't be able to you know to do this
because of some type of epidemic that's
not I think even if 3 gets cancelled
Microsoft's to do they say I mean cuz it
might not even part of e3 really oh yeah
yeah no don't they have no no they have
a this you say they say kiss I wish all
I think ESA castles nuts if Microsoft
does a whole week of Microsoft love if
these do pull out so the true leader
that you are it will be so gangster that
you still control yo JD gamer it all up
to the iron Lords to spread the truth
about e3 supremacy and call out all the
fakers with their crazy agendas hashtag
evil is forever call them out King how
you feel about that yo J deva-vrata
today Bevin like this is a live show
let's get three more legs get out of
here but look I said what you had to say
I would say when everybody say what they
had to say it's fluid y'all we'll see
how it plays out we would we hope to
stay gets good tape and we hope
definitely that it still continues
because I was even order to be out there
so we got a new focus there's no
polarizing polls are back new il people
disappear the people have not spoken
with the majority of the major
PlayStation 4 release days we reveal for
2020 do you think the ps4 has the
greatest end of generation software
lineup in gaming history the choices are
a yes to greatness is unparalleled in
gaming be nah prop the breaks fam no
guarantees idiot of games or bangers yet
we'll see I don't care
yah and keep that same energy with the
PlayStation 2 Xbox september/october
Xbox series rocked a vote when it goes
up Lord be G Lord gene Lord macho lords
of gaming dotnet fully in the building
his their debuts on ILP salute to these
brothers made you guys tremendous if you
got tremendous writing sorry if you guys
want to go check out all the amazing
covers that these people did there's a
link to the website in the yes thank you
sir thank you so so let's get these out
Rose wit Lords of gaming dotnet finest
let us start with the G the og mister
suit jacket himself the Flies of the fly
the professional guy my god Lord G what
is like Savior III money and go to TGS
and go to XO 20
[Laughter]
you know you let the higher up Steve go
to games call me did you say go to quick
cut no doubt the Texas Way could define
people find you sure we're social medias
what's going on Twitter at 37 gene 37
and on the website just go to the
website read all the articles websites
Lords of gaming down that games
interview is amazing and the fall guys
piece is really good in the disc room
for a minute
play minute engines fast mom you okay
the king like saggy like King like that
you getting back into good graces King
like that you've an absolute pleasure
may having him in the room its first
time in IOP and of course we got knock
next Ricky of the year the Macho Man
himself
don't actor wicked advisor will find
what you got going on yeah man thank you
guys so much first of all for the
opportunity to quota packs it was we
knocked it out of the park in the back
for a better group of people to go with
it passionate hard-working guys like
really it was the time of my life that
I'll never forget I thank you guys let
me live the dream for that weekend it
was the blessing people could find me on
Twitter almost active a Hector
underscore ram roman number two such as
double i i right there and the games
catch the Lord to give me down that a
lot of pieces the next week we cook a me
about to serve we got use the content
[Music]
to the rubber foot and of course Lord
addict back in the building the
reuniting back with the Twitter my
reviews the games is coming out next
week actually really review right here
my pockets are you gotta we gotta yuri
know and of course reuniting back in the
realm sword sovereign back in the realm
Erica de Pompadour finds what you got
going on nothing to worry again to
prepare myself a will of the wisps whoa
try to finish Star Wars at some point in
time but yeah my big shout out to Lord
macho Lord genie Lord uh old school old
school style little Bob Diamond yeah of
course you guys on snout absolutely
amazing job and you guys killed it so
proud man watching know each one of
those videos go up just so damn proud it
was it was crazy what else I just man
this carnivorous killing me man they
just delayed well graphic 16 mini yeah
the minigun Road
yeah what i did when i was when i was in
already pre-ordered it so whenever they
show up amazon saw was definitely missed
good to be back in the world lord came
out here fighting the fight for gamers
so that we don't get swindled and
bamboozled just keep yelling at 500 you
find me on twitter king david OTW can
find me on kos is coming back in a whole
different fashion reimagining the juices
flowing post rooms have got done soon as
I got back got back to our hard work
also we just up our technology thanks to
the help of you guys it's it's truly
amazing and humbling to be a part of the
movement um to see the support from you
guys to see the appreciation for us you
know uploaded and stuff because it was
like total [ __ ] I have made a mistake I
send a video and it was up five minutes
it already had like 40 videos like what
the hell I say your car you gotta take
it down I did something wrong you still
got a couple we gotta put up videos for
you guys that's in the room again I
would like to reiterate those people
have joined the realm there is hitting
videos that is behind the join button
yes join up there are a ton of videos
and some audio that if you keep
listening you're gonna hear some stuff
if you listen you will hear some stuff
don't record it and put that out Thanks
because you will be banished on we will
banish you about to go to the Cheesecake
Factory
we put on some pounds babies go let's go
crowds love cheesecake it's lieutenant
cake man killing it out there packs with
us
you already know honey no here y'all
fantastic to be back obviously long show
a lot to talk about but again salute
emoji gaming that net all the riders
everybody and also I wouldn't own I want
to thank a lot of the developers and
people that we met that we cross paths
with you don't say anybody who cross but
I forgot to shout my man Doc squiddy you
know I'm saying I finally got a chance
to meet him as a ton of people that I
finally got a chance to meet in the
flesh and shout to all developers you
know for the first time showcasing in
games you know just as much as that is
stressful for us to cover you could tell
sometimes in shuttle for them this their
first time and it's sometimes nervous
tough social ooh to them on that and
everyone and either retweeted the
articles or or shock shot at us out from
a development or publisher standpoint we
appreciate y'all and again we really
really appreciate support launch of
gaming down there is really moving and
it's all thanks to you guys all thanks
to the writers the editors everybody on
the team it is a long day Kings got to
go get that birthday on I got to eat if
anybody got anything else enjoy your
Sunday we'll be back next week catch
y'all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]